hi my name is Samantha Kerr wall and I
represent fortis healthcare as a
participant of the indie economics of it
I have really enjoyed my two and a half
days that I've spent out here starting
first with the private sessions in the
health care industry which were held on
Saturday where we discussed some
innovative delivery models which are
which the forum has actually put
together from studies done around the
world in a partnership that has been
launched in conjunction to that and
during my next two days I have actually
enjoyed the level of participation that
that the forum has been able to put to
put out here in Mumbai which includes a
highest level of leadership from the
policy public policy arena we have the
chief minister of maharashtra including
ship mr. from other states the vice
president of india as well so that was
an enjoyable experience learning not
only from the policy front but also from
the private sector on multitude of
issues which are facing India and even
beyond India on a global context
affecting the world today so those are
my